i'm one of the long nail goddesses
it's a community of ladies with long
nails
long nails have been a part of my life
practically all my life
the first lady is the pastor's wife
[Applause]
traditionally first ladies have big hats
short nails and i'm a first lady with
long nails and
fascinators
tradition doesn't define me so why would
i cut my nails for church
if i can't come in being who i am what
good am i going to do for anybody
sitting on any one of these roads
everybody is somebody at first zone hill
baptist church the long nail goddess
sisters feel just as welcome as anybody
else
[Music]
tell her we leaving the church
we own as well
maria has been doing my nails for about
five years
every week i go for four to five hours
to get my nails done hi baby
when she opens the floor she opens her
doors for all of us to come together
that's our community
i've been doing nails almost 23 years
since i was young i already knew i was
different
it definitely
helped me to identify with my girls
i came out in the 80s
as transgender
and it was very difficult for me being
ostracized
by society
i know what it is to be rejected knowing
how that feels i created a safe haven
for the girls and i needed that myself
we are a family
[Music]
people ask me questions like how do you
do anything i clean my baseboards i
clean my oven i put contacts in
they grew i didn't glue them on
they grew so that's how i know how to
use them
when we're out in the world
people
say nasty things
some whisper
it's so rude
it hurts
but i can talk to maria i can vent
she doesn't realize the power that she
have with being able to build a person's
spirit with nails
and when i leave out of there it's like
okay my nails look beautiful i feel
beautiful and i'm revived i'm charged
let's go
[Music]
it's just like heaven you know you laugh
you joke we talk to one another about
this and that and i love just being here
people speak different languages but we
all speak this one language and we all
live this right here i love these girls
they are the sisters that i don't have i
have six brothers and these are the
women in my life our community at the
salon that's where i go get my mojo back
so to speak so that's what we do when we
gather we help each other
seeing my long nail goddess sisters
sit in my peer at church is the most
amazing experience
that also lets me know that beyond our
salon walls we support each other
the long nail goddesses it's a community
of love